i have to start with something that i am  absolutely freaking out over which is uh  the fact that you are going to play  batman again um and i just wanted to  know as a huge fan what was it like  stepping on set for the first time  wearing that batman costume  again after so many years  weirdly and and ironically easy  uh  and a little bit emotional and  just a rush of uh  uh memories  um and  without giving anything away because it  can't uh  the first the basically the first  shot  not of the entire movie but the first  kind of let's say introduction  uh is so good  uh  that  when we walked on and we started  talking about  a couple of shots and the angles i went  whoa  this is uh  this is big this is great i mean i mean  i mean for me i mean i mean the imagery  is really it's just great great and  reminiscent  to some degree of tim burton